[Music]
[Music]
so this might be obvious but I haven't
really thought about it until now
so here when trying to figure out which
hand to be putting on top of one another
when the hands are overlapping
whatever line that has to use the thumb
end is using the thumb more often than
the other one supposed to put that
underneath because it's really hard to
play with your thumb with your wrists
really high because if one hand is above
the other one has to be placed above
maybe you can figure out a different
fingering where you're using less thumb
for whatever hand you decide to put on
top and another thing is obviously
whatever hand that has the busier part
it's more comfortable putting on below
so that you're not kind of tripping over
your other hand so the fingering in the
book actually has no thumb for the right
hand for the last five beats I actually
think it's not necessary to play that
last low G with a two and I think the
hands are part of action of her mind at
a faster tempo the thumb is a little
uncomfortable
[Music]